[Music]
this was the day one woman had the love
and support of an entire city
eight-year-old daughter Saffy Rose was
the youngest victim of the Manchester
bomb two years ago but I feel that were
taken taking a forward into the future
with us by doing this and it's I don't
think people can understand that you
need to do that you need to take them
into the future with you because you
can't see a future without them I do in
this that helps Lisa have been holding
her daughter's hand when the bomb went
off and spent six weeks in a coma she
woke up to hear the news that her
daughter had died she then had to
overcome life-changing injuries herself
Lisa walking this race today if I could
have explained to people the Lisa I
first met who could barely walk into my
office I think they'll have an idea that
about what it means for her to be doing
this today and in some way she
symbolizes the place doesn't she that
will never be broken that will always
keep going and I think everybody will be
touched by what Lisa is doing today one
of the people helping in the aftermath
of the explosion at the ariana grande
concert was this firefighter he's now
taken on the challenge of running 22
races one for each of the victims for it
to get herself in a position to not only
come back to Manchester which is a
massive deal for the families and the
other victims but you know that have
been left out but for it to get herself
into a race like this it's unbelievable
she's the hero not me ten kilometres
later she finished just as she had
started
with the support of everyone here how do
you feel about this city the most
amazing city in the world it really is I
think nothing called the cities could
learn a lot from this city top arbiter
Sky News Majesty